لقد رفضوا التفاوض بشكل جيد
سأذكرك بكل شيء في اسطنبول
وافقت أنا أقول لك هذا
ممثل الحكومة البلدية حسنا،
يجب أن يعرف جميع مواطني روسيا بالطبع
لكنك تعمل مباشرة مع الناس
اتفقنا على كل شيء وأكثر
رئيس مجموعات التفاوض مع
حتى أن الجانب الأوكراني وضع تحت هذا
لي
التوقيع موجود على وثيقتنا
أكاذيب قيل لنا للتو أننا بحاجة إلى إشارة
نوع من التقديم هنا
روسيا حقا
ينوي الذهاب إلى حل هذه
المسائل السلمية تحتاج إلى قوات
يسلب من كييف أخذوا بعيدا في يوم واحد
رمى جميع الاتفاقيات في سلة المهملات
لقد قالوا الآن علنا، من بين أمور أخرى،
رئيس غرفة المفاوضات هذه
المجموعات وهو بالمناسبة
زعيم الحزب الحاكم في
قال البرلمان في الرادا نعم كنا كذلك
على استعداد لتفويت لأنني وصلت
ثم
رئيس وزراء بريطانيا العظمى السيد .
لقد أقنعنا جونسون بعدم التنفيذ
هذه الاتفاقيات هي البلهاء
لا، وبصراحة، حسنًا، إذا كان ذلك فقط
لذلك كنا قد ذهبنا لهذا منذ وقت طويل
كان من الممكن أن يكون قد اكتمل عام ونصف
حسنًا، هذه مجرد مرة أخرى
ويؤكد أنهم ليسوا مستقلين
الناس هذا أمر مفهوم للجميع وهذا لكل شيء
السلام هذا
بوضوح
ن